a general overview of the islamic
religion as taught in schools and
otherwise often divide the religion into
two major
branches the sunni and the shia and
while this is of course a very
simplified view there's in fact a lot of
other groups and schools of thought and
sub-branches within these two major
branches
it does point to two very
sometimes distinct and significant
communities of muslims both the sunni
and the shia are in themselves divided
into various sub-branches and schools of
thought but when many perhaps most
people talk about shia islam or the
shi's they are usually referring to
the most major branch of shia islam the
kind of shiiism associated with iran and
the government there the ayatollahs and
places of learning like
this branch of shiism is usually
referred to as the ithna ashari or the
twelver she is also sometimes known as
the imami shia and in this episode we'll
be giving you a general overview of the
history and intellectual development of
this very significant islamic community
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this video is in collaboration with
hikmah history an excellent historical
youtube channel that is just doing a
video covering how iran turned to shia
islam as its official state doctrine
this is one of the most important events
in the history of shiism and that is
exactly why we are doing this
collaboration i will be covering
12verizon more generally and he will be
giving an overview of the developments
in the safavid empire and later
dynasties which are so important the
twelver or imami shia is a very
significant community within islam today
about 15 to 20 percent of muslims in the
world are shiis and almost 85 of those
shiites belong to the twelver branch in
particular
it holds political power in iran and
thus also serves as an important player
in world politics but where do the
twelvers come from the even more general
division of islam into sunni and shia
has at its core a debate over authority
they all believe in the prophecy of
muhammad and the revelation of the quran
but after the prophet died who was
supposed to succeed him and in what way
the group that would later come to be
known as sunni believed that political
authority was passed on to chosen
members of muhammad's community the
or caliphs and eventually accepted as
righteous the first four abu bakr omar
uthman and ali
later caliphates like the umayyads and
abbasids were often considered
legitimate leaders as representatives of
the prophet and god but are not revered
in the same way as the first four in
terms of religious or spiritual
authority the sunnis would later come to
recognize the community of scholars the
ulama as the source of authority on law
and belief as well as the sufi sheikhs
and saints the shia had a different view
instead they held that authority to lead
the community was passed down and the
prophet's family
partly in a more general sense of being
part of the hashimi clan but later
becoming narrowed down specifically to
the alid family line the progeny of
muhammad's daughter fatima and ali his
cousin
indeed the name shia originally comes
from the term shiat ali or the party of
ali it is believed by shiis that ali was
the true successor to muhammad a rule he
had been given officially at the event
of
ali thus became the first so-called imam
of the sheis and plays an enormous role
in their theology and doctrines the
title of imam or rightful leader was
then passed down from ali to his son
hassan then to his brother hussain and
then continued in a line of patrilineal
succession in the earliest period there
were many debates around rightful
authority in the muslim community we can
in no way talk about a simple shia sunni
divide at this time these communities as
fixed identities wouldn't be formulated
until many centuries later instead there
were many different claimants to
authority both politically and
religiously some of whom legitimized
their rule simply on power or other
factors while others the alis did so
based on their direct familial
connection to the prophet early shiism
is a difficult topic with many competing
accounts but it seems that it was in
many ways a kind of messianic movement
many imams sons of ali and their sons
and their sons etc who claimed authority
and gained followers but according to
later established shia doctrine there is
a certain line of imams that is
considered quote unquote correct or
authoritative any later division of
shiism into further branches is
determined by which line of imams a
certain community sees as true or
legitimate in shiism there has to always
be an imam in the world a person who has
been given the knowledge or elim to
interpret the quran and the sunnah of
the prophet in the correct way and adapt
adapted to new situations and times
he the imam is given this knowledge by
the previous imam who is his father who
received it from the imam before him and
so on
this designation of the new imam the
continuing of the line of imams is
called nas and is central to shia belief
the albeit or family of the prophet
muhammad has been given the role to lead
his community through their intimate and
direct knowledge of the essence of the
quranic message it's not that the quran
is incomplete per se as i alluded to in
a previous episode but the quran
requires there to be an imam who has
agnostic or true knowledge of its
meaning so that he can interpret it
correctly for the muslims
the shii's criticized their proto-sunni
counterparts for relying too much on
their own minds in interpreting and
understanding religion leading to
division and confusion regarding beliefs
and practices
instead there is always an imam a
possessor of full knowledge who has the
authority to interpret the religion and
to adapt it to new times and
circumstances and according to the major
schools of shiism there is always only
one imam at any given time
so the religious and spiritual essence
of shia islam always revolve around a
single pole a single point that
determines all points and aspects the
imam
and this is true for all prophetic
cycles
earlier prophets like moses or jesus
also had imams that succeeded them there
simply cannot be any religion without an
imam to lead people in this religion
thus this doctrine of the imamites is at
the core of all shia belief and
spirituality
it is the main point that distinguishes
them from the sunnis even though they
have developed many other unique
features too
and again the main difference between
different branches of shiism is that
they accept different lines of imams to
be correct
the two largest branches the twelver or
ithnashadi or umami's and the second
largest the ismailis all agree on the
first six imams
ali the son-in-law and cousin of the
prophet is the first imam
he was followed by his son hassan the
imamit was then inherited by his brother
ali's other son hussein after hassan was
martyred in the battle of karbala in 680
an event that would become central to
shia consciousness and belief his son
ali zainal abedin became the next imam
followed by his son muhammad al-baqr and
finally the last imam that they all
accept as canonical is jafar assad
jaffar assad is one of the most central
of the imams as he is often thought of
as having originated or at least
formulated many of the core shia beliefs
for the first time he said have held an
enormous amount of knowledge of all
things religion as well as things
relating to esotericism and the occult
indeed according to many later writers
all esoteric teachings within islam
something that is especially prominent
in different shi'i branches originate
with the imams and jaffar asadik is one
of the most prominent in this regard
he is for example thought to have been
the teacher of the famous alchemist
jaber ibn haiyan even the sunnis like
him and consider jaffa to have been a
teacher of law to people like abu hanifa
and malik ibn anas two of the most
foundational figures of sunni islamic
jurisprudence although the sunnis will
often hold that jaffa wasn't a shia imam
as such but a sunni scholar but you know
still in any case there was a great
split in the community after the death
of jaffa rasadek
some believe that his eldest son ismail
was the rightful successor and these
became known as the ismailis
another group instead followed his
youngest son musal chasm and this is the
group that we know as the 12 verse
this name is connected to the number of
imams now remember jaffar as-sadiq was
the sixth imam so musa al-qasim is the
seventh he was followed by ali al-riddha
then muhammad jawad al-taqi then ali
al-hadi followed by hasan al-askari and
lastly muhammad al-mahdi who was the
last and twelfth imam the last imam was
only a young boy when he was given the
title after his father had passed and
tradition holds that he immediately went
into a lesser occultation or he went
into hiding and only communicated with
his community through a few advisors
this continued for a number of years
until 9 41 when he is thought to have
gone into the major occultation
this meant that he could no longer be
contacted and would not be seen by
anyone until the end of time
he thus became al-mahdi a kind of
messianic figure and it is thought that
this 12th imam will return at the end of
time just before judgement day to set
the world right again and reinstate true
religion and devotion this became a
major turning point in twelve irishism
as we will see and began a phase in
their history that remains to this day
as we saw earlier according to shii
belief there can be no time when there
is no imam present to lead the community
and so according to the shi's al-mahdi
isn't dead he is still out there
somewhere in hiding and will return when
the appropriate time has come and while
he is gone he is
temporarily represented by the scholars
of the community this is where they get
the name ethni which means 12 or 12
right because they believed that there
were 12 imams that succeeded muhammad
and that the 12th imam is the last one
who has gone into hiding and will return
in time for judgment day so this was the
earliest period and you could say the
first phase of twelve or shiism the
phase or time when the imams were still
present to lead the community now
remember this was before there was
anything like a clear distinction
between sunni and shia but the shiis had
definitely formed a unique community
based around these worldly and spiritual
leaders of the imam and thus
distinguished themselves from
many other muslims at the time but what
is shiism like other than these basic
facts
what are the beliefs and practices that
made them stand out
well you could say that there was a
clear shift or clear distinction
between the first period the period of
the imams and the period after the
occultation of the last or twelfth imam
the earliest period of shii history is
quite obscure and there is a lot of
debate in scholarship regarding the
nature of its doctrines some view the
early period as one of strict legalism
which later became influenced by
esoteric currents while many today
emphasized that the esoteric aspects and
many features of the imamit were in
place basically from the beginning what
seems clear to most is that in terms of
jurisprudence or law as well as to some
degree theology the early shiites
differed in some significant ways from
their proto-sunni counterparts
while there are examples of companions
of the imams that engage in theological
speculation and debate the imams and
their followers appeared to have had a
rather strict attitude towards matters
of law and doctrine
whereas many of the proto-sunni schools
especially in the earliest period
allowed for different forms of
independent interpretation and rational
deduction in deriving law what is often
called
meaning opinion and things like analogy
us the shiites were very much against
these kinds of practices
there was no room for independent
reasoning and interpretation on part of
the jurists in the early period
and similar attitudes appeared to have
been held in terms of theological
speculation too this is true of both the
twelver shiites as well as the ismailis
at the time scripture and revelation was
the only source of doctrine this makes
complete sense really remember to the
shiites the imam was the absolute
authority on all things religion
he had the true inner knowledge of the
quran and the sunnah and could interpret
and reinterpret them in the correct way
so why would you ever start reasoning
and interpreting things for yourself
when you could just go ask the living
imam for the answer which would always
be the true and correct interpretation
so it is partly as a result of the
presence of the living imam as a person
who carries the quranic message and its
complete interpretation that we get this
restrictive attitude the imam has
complete authority and has all the
answers whereas in the proto-sunni world
there was no absolute leader but up to
the community of scholars to figure out
the answers as best they could
but once the 12th imam went into
occultation and was no longer reachable
by the community
what happens then
what do the shiites do when they don't
have that central authority at least
not present in the world to ask
questions and to get the right
interpretation at all times well this is
the reason probably at least one of the
major reasons why we see a
very clear shift in emphasis and
methodology when it comes to law and
also to some degree theology
right after the time of the occultation
it is in this period that we get some of
the most formative scholars in shia
history figures like sheikh mufild and
his students like sharif al-murtada and
sheikh tulsi would establish some of the
key features of twelver shiism as we
know it today and instigate a major
shift in its intellectual trajectory
sheikh mofidd put a major emphasis on
reason as an important part in
understanding and interpreting religious
practice and belief whereas earlier the
trend had been a much more strict
following of the scripture and the
teachings of the imam but because the
imam was in occultation this was a new
era in which jurists had to figure
things out without the imam and for that
reason and intellect akhel was central
it is sheikh murphyd who started the
process of bringing together shiism with
the heavily rationalistic school of
calam theology known as the mua tesla
albeit a bit modified to fit the shia
tradition an influence that is still
central to shia theology today sheikh
tuzi one of mufid's students is
sometimes also considered the founder of
shia juris prudence properly and
compiled two of the four major shia
collections of hadith in other words
with these thinkers in the immediate
aftermath of the great occultation we
see a major shift in shia methodology
and intellectual thought from a quite
literalist and strict confined tendency
in the period of the imams to a post
imam period that was characterized
primarily by the huge emphasis on
reason and intellect as well as personal
interpretation hd had as the major
components of shii thought a
characteristic that still is central to
that tradition today now it should be
kept in mind that some scholars disagree
with this version of events writers like
hussein modaresi instead emphasized that
the companions of the imams themselves
did engage in reasoning and
interpretations in terms of law and
doctrine and that it was only in the 9th
to 10th century that the more
traditionist tendency took over like i
said the early history is often disputed
and it's important to keep different
perspectives in mind in any case a huge
emphasis on reason from the 11th century
onwards is often placed in contrast to
the different schools of sunni
jurisprudence which at around this time
is often said to have done away with hd
had or interpretation and instead
entered a period of taqlid imitation and
following of already established legal
presidents of course these are huge
generalizations and to say that these
sunnis abandoned each day their
interpretation is simply incorrect they
would continue of course to reinterpret
things just like the shi'is did
but there is a certain difference in
emphasis in that in the four major
schools of sunni law
most
topics had been covered previously and
there was a tendency in these schools to
imitate or to look at the previously
established legal rulings from their
particular school and simply follow
those traditions rather than going back
to the original sources and
reinterpreting things for themselves
right and in shiism
again while this is a huge
generalization in shiism from this
period and until today there has been a
much bigger emphasis on this process of
hd had of reinterpreting or going back
to the sources the hadith of the prophet
of the imams and the quran and using the
or the reason and intellect of
well of the jurist himself to
interpret
law
and also theology to some degree for
themselves the relationship between the
shiis and what would later become known
as the sunnis is a complicated topic in
some regards they aren't that different
from each other at all and can seem
indistinguishable from each other and in
other respects they can be very distinct
and different in a general sense the
twelver shia follow the same basic
practices as their sunni counterparts
they pray five times a day they fast
during ramadan they give to charity and
so on
the quran is considered the word of god
as the primary source in all matters as
is the sunnah of the prophets the major
difference here is the role of the imams
who not only have a sunnah of their own
but also have the absolute authority to
interpret the sunnah of the prophet
himself as well as the sunnah of earlier
imams and the quran in this way the
twelver shia as we saw earlier also have
collections of hadith that they use as
basis for law and theology but they have
different collections of hadiths from
the sunnis the sunnis have their sahih
bukhari and sahih muslim etc but the
shiites have different ideas about which
of the companions of the prophet are
more or less trustworthy and so have
other chains of transmission when it
comes to hadith the shia also have
hadiths about the imams and their lives
and teachings aside from hadiths about
the prophet muhammad and these imam and
hadiths are also authoritative in the
same way
the four main books of hadith in shiism
are the kitab al-kafi manlaya
tahavi bella kam and al esther
later two of which are by the
aforementioned sheikh tusi there are
also practices that characterize shiism
in important ways one of the most
significant of these is the annual
holiday known as ashura the
commemoration of the martyrdom of imam
hussain
in 680 the third shia imam and grandson
of the prophet muhammad hussain ibn ali
fought a battle against the forces of
the umayyad king of yazid in karbala
iraq
both he and most of his family were
martyred in this encounter and this
event is one of the central features of
shia history and consciousness it often
comes to represent the xi's role as a
minority that faces oppression of
tyrannical rulers and this event is
commemorated each year in what is known
as ashura where there are various
rituals performed
one will often beat one's own chest in a
kind of solidarity with imam hussein's
suffering and go on pilgrimage to his
shrine in kerabala which is a massive
complex in iraq today and this visiting
of shrines in general known as ziada is
also an important component of shiism
one will visit the graves of the imams
as an important religious practice the
pilgrimage to karbala and imam hussain
is by far the largest and most
significant and can sometimes even equal
the hajj to mecca in importance from
this these shi'is have developed in
various ways that have differed from the
proto-sunnis and later sunnis the
adoption of matasa light theology means
that they viewed god as a unified
essence without various attributes as
part of that essence but instead as
identical to that essence this is a
theological jargon but this was quite an
important
topic and debates in theological circles
at this time they have also often
emphasized a certain level of
esotericism and various doctrines about
the imams and other things are often
initiatory and secretive in nature
indeed one of the key features of shii
thinking in general is the division of
reality and most things in it into two
categories the exoteric the zaher and
the esoteric batin
reality itself has an outer visible
aspect as well as an inner invisible
aspect and in terms of religion and
doctrine the same is true
the quran has a zahid and a botan an
apparent meaning and a hidden esoteric
meaning that can be extracted through
esoteric interpretation known as tawil
indeed the sixth imam jaffar assad is
believed to have said quote the book of
god comprises four things the statements
set down the implied purport the hidden
meanings relating to the supersensible
world and the exalted spiritual
doctrines
throughout shii history we see an
emphasis on this division of the zaher
and barten of things
as another example there is the idea of
the esoteric and exoteric imam
the exoteric imam is the actual person
of the imam who guides the community in
the world while the esoteric imam is the
akhl within every human being although
not necessarily akhil has understood in
later imamism as the intellect or reason
as such but rather an earlier conception
of the word meaning a faculty of
consciousness that is able to recognize
god and the truth a kind of inner divine
guide that complements the outer divine
guide of the human imam
this esotericism of shiism is really
prominent throughout its history and at
least according to many scholars today
like muhammad ali amirmuzi can be found
in the earliest teachings of the imams
themselves and their followers
reading the earliest choices we get
fascinating statements from and about
the imams regarding their cosmological
role the prophet muhammad always has the
highest and most exalted role as a
prophet a title that none of the imams
are ever given but they are nonetheless
called the hujat allah the proof of god
and as the aosiya the guardians are
custodians of muhammad's revelation thus
shiism has always been esoteric in the
sense that it is somewhat initiatory it
is only the followers of the imams those
who have been given the true esoteric
interpretations and understanding of the
islamic religion that constitute true
believers and practice true islam
everyone else is the people of zaher the
people who only follow the outer
meanings and practices of the religion
and fail to see its true spiritual
meanings which can only be taught by the
imams
this is true of early shi'i practices as
well
according to some sources there appear
to have been what we could call
spiritual or mystical practices in early
shiism primarily concerned with quote
vision with the heart
this was probably a practice and theory
taught to initiates that included
prayers and other teachings so that one
could see god or experience god in some
way through the heart the shi'is have
always had a very transcendent view of
god like most muslims god is of course
utterly beyond any description or
understanding by humans as such he can
never be seen with the eyes but he can
in some way be seen with the eye of the
heart
and these early mystical practices of
shiism appear to have focused on this
practitioners could experience the light
of the imam through this vision of the
heart as well as other divine
experiences
given how early these sources are this
is very significant in later sufism or
tasawolf the idea of the heart as the
human faculty able to experience god in
some way would become a central theme
this has led some scholars to connect
these and figures like android corban
have argued that all mysticism and
esotericism in islam originally comes
out of early shiism and the teachings of
the imams other scholars will disagree
with this and i would definitely argue
that this is an oversimplification but
it is very fascinating nonetheless the
imams in themselves are also attributed
with various miraculous and superhuman
powers not only are they considered to
be infallible according to majority xi
opinion but many stories also tell of
how they had access to occult and
esoteric powers both through their inner
knowledge of the secrets of the quran
and of reality but also through
employing things like astrology and even
originating the science of letters or
roof which became so popular in later
islamic mysticism one of the sources of
these esoteric powers is thought to be
their knowledge of the most supreme name
of god which was only taught to the
prophet muhammad and to the imams and
which is composed of 73 letters
one of these letters is only known to
god but various prophets and figures in
history have known a few of the letters
and this has been the source of their
magical powers jesus for example could
perform all his miracles just by knowing
two of the letters and the same goes for
the imams who together with the prophet
muhammad knew 72 of these letters and
thus were capable of amazing feats
so the imams again is central to shii
belief
doctrine
it is a central pole around which all of
shiism revolves essentially whether it's
traversim or the ismailis or all
branches of shiism is
centered around this figure of the imam
whether he is a living mom in the world
or an imam in occultation
i mean in both cases he remains the
central pole of the entire religion
or yeah the entire religion according to
she is and the absence of the imam the
imam who is in occultation is a
significant factor for practices and
intelligence as well as we saw earlier
as another example of this it is
believed that only the imam can lead the
community in jihad in the form of armed
struggle or war but when there is no
imam there can be no such war
this means that the twelver shiis don't
perform any form of offensive military
jihad but only that of the defensive
kind protecting the borders already
established now some scholars especially
in the safavid
empire for example
you know there could be loopholes to
this doctrine when you're ruling an
empire you need to be able to do
offensive war in some way usually at
least so
there are nuances to this but in general
this could be said to be true even today
and many twelver xiii scholars today
still hold to this general opinion that
no offensive jihad or war can ever be
performed while the imam is absent
despite this though the twelvers have
gained political power on occasion even
before the revolution in iran in 1979.
the brides who ruled the central lands
of the islamic world in the 10th and
11th century adopted twelver shiism
this was at the same time that the
fatimids ruled further west in egypt who
were themselves ismaili shiites so this
was a time when shiism all the different
branches of shiism ruled significant
portions of the islamic world a
situation that played a major role in
the formation of what we know as sunni
islam today as a kind of response to
this precarious situation
another significant example is indeed
the later establishment of the safavid
dynasty in persia and thus we have
reached that meeting point of our
discussion today
by then shiism had continued to develop
intellectually from the days of people
like sheikh murphyd and we see a
basically fully developed system of
jewish prudence as well as other
flourishing intellectual philosophical
and mystical tendencies here's hikmah
history himself to tell you more about
the safavids
the safavid started out as a sufi tariqa
that over time evolved into a
militarized shia order which vied for
power on the persian plateau
under shah ismail first
they established a dynasty which ruled
persia for the next 200 years
they would go on to enforce 12ishism as
the new state religion and sought to
convert their citizens to the creed
in the process positioning themselves as
the arch rivals of the sunni ottomans to
the west
with who they fought countless wars
throughout the 16th and 17th centuries
in the east they were able to extend
their rule over parts of afghanistan and
central asia
during the course of their rule they
left behind a rich cultural legacy that
is best exemplified by their imperial
capital esfahan
where symbols of their architectural
brilliance can still be seen today in
the many landmarks in the city such as
the nakshi jahan square
back to you philip
in terms of jewish prudence or islamic
law the safavid era saw some significant
changes and developments
the school of law followed by the
twelver she is is called the jaffari
school named after that very significant
sixth imam jaffar assad
and which has been developed by such
significant figures as sheikh tuzi and
his later followers under the influence
of these scholars shiila had again
become heavily reliant on reason
and aged he had interpretation by a
qualified jurist known as the mujtahid
but under the safavids this
rationalistic tendency was challenged by
a resurgence of the traditionist school
who rejected independent reasoning in
terms of law and instead focused on a
much more strict literalism of only
using the written sources of the quran
and the hadith from this movement the
jaffari school of law came to be divided
into two schools or tendencies the usuli
which are the rationalists and the
akhbaris the traditionalists
and indeed from the osulis being
basically undisputed the akhbadis grew
so much in prominence during the safarid
era that they made up the majority of
shia scholars during most of the 18th
century
however since the 19th century the
ussulis once again gained the upper hand
and today the absolute majority of shi's
follow the rationalistic usuli school
so why did this great shift suddenly
happen during the safavid empire
well one thing could be that the shiites
were suddenly in political power of a
major empire which led to new questions
having to be asked about the law in
relation to that new position thus new
discussions took place and new schools
emerged in general the jaffari school of
shiila isn't all that different from the
schools of sunni law at all
in most ways in terms of law they are
basically identical but they can differ
in certain details the xi's have a
different position of the hands and arms
when they pray the daily salah prayers
for example compared to the majority of
sunnis another major factor in shiite
history and doctrine is the idea of
taqiyya so because the shi'is have often
been a minority in sunni ruled lands
they have faced oppression and
persecution from
[Music]
the
majority community
and because of this
they developed this idea of takriya that
it is permissible
in extreme situations for shiites to
hide their identity basically to hide
the fact that they are shi's and perhaps
pretend to be sunni muslims to avoid
persecution so this
has been a very important part of shiism
throughout history
which is not as prominent at all in
sunni islam
the she is also generally differ from
the sunnis in allowing temporary
marriage mutta and other such relatively
minor details
and we also saw their differing attitude
towards jihad or arms struggled before
so there are certain differences but in
general and in most ways the jaffari
school of shiite law is very similar to
the
sunni schools of law but even outside
the realm of law and jurisprudence the
shi'i intellectual traditions really
flourished during these safavid era
it is in this period that we see some of
the most significant and
influential intellectuals philosophers
and scholars in history we have for
example the great school of isfahan in
which philosophy flourished under great
figures like meeru damad and his even
more famous and influential student
mulla sadra these figures created a kind
of synthetic philosophy that combined
the peripatetic works of ibencina with
more mystical or sufi strands of
thinking such as suravardi and the great
eben arabi this relationship between
shiism and mysticism
sufism is a complicated one but one that
is definitely interesting
as we saw earlier there were definitely
things that could be considered mystical
from the earliest days of shiism to the
point that some have even claimed that
islamic mysticism and esotericism
originates in that movement
but in terms of mysticism in the form of
sufism things get a little more
difficult sufism or tasawolf in arabic
is indeed for the most part a sunni
affair most sufi orders and figures are
and were sunnis now there are exceptions
to this for example the matulahi order
which i have made an episode about
previously but in the general sense this
can be considered to be true but that
doesn't mean that sufism didn't
influence she thought far from it
actually
whereas in sunni islam we talk about
tasawaf or sufism in shiism the
preferred term or tradition came to be
something that is called irfan which is
sometimes translated as something like
gnostic knowledge or gnosticism which if
you watched my earlier episodes can
obviously be pretty pretty problematic
what is meant is a kind of mystical
wisdom of philosophy distinct from a
simply rationalistic falsehood tradition
of people like eben cena or eben rust
what this means in practice is that many
ideas within sufism primarily its
metaphysical speculations and some
psychological theories were very much
adapted by shii thinkers as essential to
a comprehensive understanding of islamic
doctrine and spirituality but instead
they went under the name irfan rather
than sufism which was often looked down
upon especially in the safavid era what
wasn't adopted usually were the
practical aspects of sufism
that is what sufism was according to the
critical she thinkers various ecstatic
practices that were considered
questionable according to the law but
that didn't mean that the philosophical
ideas of the sufis and their view of
reality was incorrect
so this latter theoretical part was
often accepted and called erfan while
many of the practical aspects in other
words sufism was rejected
these are oversimplifications of course
but you get the general idea this
hostile attitude of the safavids and
their scholars against sufism per se is
especially fascinating given the fact
that the safavid dynasty actually
originated as a sufi order in the words
of alexander knish quotes as a result in
the iranian she emilia the nobler
metaphysical cosmological and
gnostiological aspects of sufism were
excluded from this notion and renamed as
wisdom hikma transcendental philosophy
hekmatel muttaalia or divine gnosis
irfan
simultaneously the notion of sufism
tasawolf per se was demoted to the
antisocial behavior and crude
superstition of the antinomian
ignoramuses the doctrines of the great
sufi master ibn arabi himself a staunch
sunni became widely adopted into the
later shi'i mysticism or irfan
the relatively early figure of haidar
amuli is very important in this regard
as he became heavily influenced by the
school of ibn adabi in particular and
also came to adapt those ideas into a
more clearly xi framework including the
doctrine of the imams etc but it was
especially with the writings of the
already mentioned mullah sadra that this
really took off mulla sadra combined the
parapathetic teachings of ibn sina the
illuminationist thought of suravardi and
the mystical doctrines of ibn arabi to
create a philosophy that he called
al-hikmat al-muta'aliyah the
transcendent wisdom or transcendent
philosophy
the thought of mullah sadra and the
tradition of erfan became paradigmatic
in shiism ever since he is often
considered the most influential
philosopher in islamic history after ibn
cena at least in the eastern and shii
worlds
all the great shii scholars to this day
study mulasadra and his mystical
philosophy as an essential part of their
training to some it may be surprising to
learn that some of the great ayatollahs
in iran and elsewhere were hugely
influenced by mysticism and the thought
of mulasadra even ayatollah khomeini was
an expert on mulasadra and on the
tradition of irfan in general indeed in
1989 romania actually sent a letter to
the then soviet leader gorbachov and
basically invited him to convert to
islam as a better
ideology than the communism of the
soviets at the time and in the process
he actually sent gorbachev a copy of ibn
arabis for salhekam or the ringstones of
wisdom as a book that
to him basically represented the
religion of islam in the best way and
would sort of make gorbachev want to
convert in other words the world is
complicated and things like mysticism is
often hugely oversimplified and colored
by modern new age thinking but the
reality situation is a lot more
complicated than that eid fan has been a
central part of xi intellectual thought
until today and we can thus see that
while its relationship with sufism is
complicated there has always been an
exchange of ideas between different
schools of islam but what also becomes
clear is that the safavid era is really
a watershed moment in the history of
imam ishiiism generally
being given political power resulted in
some very significant developments in
all kinds of fields of knowledge jewish
prudence philosophy quote-unquote
mysticism and even to some degree
certain art forms like music this era
and the following centuries of khaljad
rule also saw the increasing role of the
jurists as leaders of the community as
well as the representatives of the
hidden imam
a few years into safavid ruled the
actual shahs or kings of the empire lost
a large amount of their power and the
fukaha the jurists essentially came to
have the largest amount of power as we
saw in the shi'i tradition of law
especially in the dominant usuli school
there is a major emphasis on hd had
personal interpretation and the jurist
who was trained enough that he had the
authority to practice ishta had is known
as a mujtahid the mujtahids and juris
generally continued to hold very
significant power in iran and in persia
and the shiite world some would argue
that their power increased more and more
over time a development that basically
culminated in the doctrine of the
walayath
the guardianship of the jurists which
was formulated by ayatollah khomeini in
the 20th century the title ayatollah
which literally means sign of god came
to be used primarily in the 20th century
to denote the highest authorities in chi
islam and includes people like khomeini
as well as the very popular sistani
today
and the doctrine of the guardianship of
the jurist essentially states that in
the absence of the hidden imam the
jurist has the authority to lead the
community absolutely in religious
matters this wasn't a new idea in shiism
per se but what khomeini did was to
extend that authority to political rule
as well in other words the jurist or the
highest jurist now had the right and
indeed should be the highest authority
over the state as well even the shah
king or president of the country
and it is on this basis that the islamic
republic of iran was founded now
important to remember is that not all
shiites follow this idea and support
wilayat al-fakhakri in the absolute
sense as formulair
so even today as has always been the
case she isn't remains complex and
diverse and there are many voices and
opinions around questions such as these
but now i hope you have somewhat of a
better understanding of twelve or shiism
its history and its major doctrines and
intellectual developments
in terms of law it doesn't differ much
at all from sunni islam in most ways
except in a few details but in other
ways in terms of theology it's esoteric
doctrines and other such things they can
differ very drastically imams have at
least since the 11th century put a major
emphasis on akl on reason and intellect
in its methodologies uh in terms of law
as well as theology at the same time the
she's especially in the early period and
in ideas surrounding the imams appear to
have always emphasized very esoteric
ideas from the mystical and fantastical
stories about the imams themselves their
secret knowledge and powers to the later
development of strong currents of erfan
or mystical philosophies twelver shiaism
is a dynamic tradition
don't forget to check out hikmah
history's video about how safavid iran
adopted imami or travishism as its state
doctrine an event that as we have seen
became one of the deciding factors for
this community in many different ways
it provides an essential companion to
this episode so don't miss out on it
hikmah history does really amazing work
educating the public about topics in
islamic or islamic history so subscribe
to his channel and check out some of the
excellent material over there in the
near future we will also be going in
depth into that second largest shii
community the ismailis so stay tuned for
that but for now thank you so much for
watching
as always i want to thank my patrons who
support this channel monetarily and i
want to thank all of you out there who
comment who like and and
who are subscribed to this channel i
really appreciate your support so much
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you